being the hot young writer you know
being on the front page of variety your
names out there you're probably your
phone's ringing and I know you you've
talked in other interviews about how
some of that went away for a little bit
can you talk about if someone else is in
a similar situation how they regroup
yeah what I'd like to do is give the
single best piece of advice that I ever
got that I ignored and so what happened
is when I was in the front page of riot
II and all these offers were coming in
there was an agent at my agency Barbara
Dreyfus who didn't represent me but she
took me out to lunch and she gave me the
following advice she said the next
script you write is the most important
strip you'll ever write it will
determine the trajectory of your career
so right now you were an unknown person
now you're on everyone's radar you work
with a high profile director he's
planning on making the movie he said how
great your script was everybody in town
wants to work with you so everyone is
like so hyped up on you now there are
writers who are commodity writers they
they go in and they write these big
summer movies and these big action
movies they make a lot of money but
there's nothing special about them and
there's writers who are a less writers
writers who have these amazing careers
the next script you write will put you
on a trajectory so her advice was this
don't take any job that you wouldn't
have done for free which is to say you
love this project and you believe you
could just knock it out of the park you
love this so much
you would do it without getting paid now
we're gonna get you paid but don't take
anything that falls short of that and
you'll have to say no to a lot of stuff
because most of what they're gonna offer
you is crap or just not a good fit for
you and the offers will start to slow
down and you're gonna panic and think
you have to grab the next best one don't
and the offers will keep slowing down
and I'm telling you this that even
you'll think the offers will eventually
go away and they won't but even if they
do literally you've said no to
everything spec your next script and
make it something that you love and
knock it out apart because she said if
the next
is amazing then that puts you on a
trajectory that then people see you a
certain way later on is the time to do
it for the money
later on we'll grab a lot of money but
right now this next script that you're
on now everyone knows who you are
this next script is going to tell them
what kind of writer you are and when she
said that like I had that chill up my
spine like this is absolutely true I
need to hear this and do this and I said
no to something I said no to something
the third time I said no it was a Disney
project and they doubled my quote and I
said no and they doubled my quote and I
said yes and I'm embarrassed to say that
that project of all the projects was not
only a script I didn't want to write it
was a movie I wouldn't even want to see
but it was sudden I don't come from
money I had student debt and it was more
money than I ever thought you could make
in years and and I was gonna get paid
for three months and so the precedent
that I said I think with myself at that
point is I'm in this for the money
and and I and that really locked me into
a career path and it was I wish I could
go back in time I feel like that was a
really big test and I failed it I could
see where a lot of people would not
blame you and I'm not even sure which
project you're referring to forgive me
but I mean so you really feel like even
the money that you took and probably it
changed many things for you because
money money can do wonderful things it
can also hurt but I mean but here's the
thing if I hadn't taken that project and
that project never got made and you know
as a writing sample I think it was it
was good but it wasn't special if I'd
waited and waited and took something
else or even to something original and
if it was great I would have made so
much more money down the wrong down
though I mean so you know my agent
you know represents me but he also
represents Aaron Sorkin I work non-stop
as a studio writer for 11 years I made a
lot more money than ever thought I could
make
do you know the difference between how
much money aaron sorkin is me I don't
know but I can I'm sure that what aaron
sorkin makes is not even in the same zip
code is what I made he also represents
JK Rowling now I'm not saying that I
could have become Aaron Sorkin or that
level or I could have been JK Rowling I
don't know but what I do know is that
the choices I made prevented that from
being a possibility I was a studio
writer I just kept doing a bunch of
action movies and summer action comedy
movies sometimes I thought they were fun
sometimes I didn't but I love the
paycheck and I love just making the
money and the deal and I never stopped
and wrote from my heart I never wrote
and I'll tell you one of the main
reasons is I was so fixed mindset I was
so afraid of rejection I was so afraid
that every script I wrote I was afraid
that people would say oh you're not that
good of a writer you were fraud now if I
wrote something from my heart if I wrote
something that was authentic that
exposed me into the material now they
could say you're not a good writer and
you're not even a good person like they
could reject me as if they rejected my
material and it was very personal then
that was like they were rejecting me as
a person and that was too painful I was
not gonna allow it happen my agent was
begging me to write something authentic
and from my heart my wife was begging me
my manager was begging me my golden
retriever was begging me and I just
wouldn't and so it's just it's just a it
was short-sighted
first of all money isn't everything but
even money is everything I potentially
could have made so much more money but
more importantly I could have written
stuff that I was in love with and I
could have look maybe I would have I
could have tried for that career I could
have written authentic stuff I could
have swung for the fences I could have
tried for that a-list career and maybe
come up short and and then backed into
the career I had maybe that I there's no
I don't know but I know that the choices
I made meant I was never gonna have that
career I was never gonna be creatively
fulfilled I was never gonna be writing
the stuff that I really want to be
writing I was never gonna be writing
from love I was always gonna be writing
from fear I regret that and so part of
the reason I teach is I want to help
writers
do it the right way and help empower
them with the tool I wish someone taught
me creative integration up front and
some of the stuff but I I hope that I
can be an influence on writers so that
they can have the best possible career
that they're capable of and maybe even a
better one than that so if you were to
take yourself to lunch instead of that
woman that was it was an old are you
talking to that younger you would you
say the exact same thing I would have
and I would have said and look I'm from
the future so let me tell you and I
would have I would have told him all the
terrible things that happened and I
honestly think that that younger me
would have made the same decision and
the reason is if he he was so fixed
mindset and fixed mindset you were just
working from fear and you just can't see
the truth or you can't and hopefully
that's not true hopefully I would've but
anyway I'm not confident that I would
have made a different decision I'm not
proud of that but I think that's the
truth but I will say you know one of the
things my wife my knife always sees like
the real truth and you know one of the
things she said is like all of things
happen in my career is actually a
blessing I mean it softened me up it got
me out of this fear space and and I
wouldn't be the teacher that I am now
had I not made those mistakes and gone
through that and I did make a lot of
money which is nice so it's like you
know it it had a lot of perks but yeah I
wish I could have done it differently
you